hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
genome imaging of head and neck solid
tumors
oropharyngeal tongue and thyroid cancers
i'm christy jewel of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by bionano
genomics to learn more about our sponsor
please visit bionanogenomics.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or you
can use
the ask a question box to let us know
you're experiencing a problem
today's presentation is educational and
it offers
continuing education credits
after this presentation click on the
continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i would now like to present today's
speaker dr brandon labarge
dr labarge is an otolarynology head and
neck surgery resident
at the pennsylvania state university
college of medicine
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
welcome dr labarge you may now begin
your presentation
good morning everyone thanks for the
introduction there
um but i'll be presenting on the number
of
head and neck solid tumors using bio
nano genome imaging
uh beginning with an overview i'll start
talking with a
discussion of the solid tissue high
molecular weight dna isolation protocol
that bionicle has recently developed
i'll go over the bio nano platform in
general
and then i'll move to a number of head
and neck cancers including tongue
anaplastic thyroid
and hp hpv positive oral foreign cancer
and then wrap up with some conclusions
the bio nano sp tissue dna isolation
protocol
utilizes a nanobind disk combine the dna
without shearing the dna in any way
allowing you to obtain
high molecular weight dna which is at
least 150 000 base pair in length
it also uses a magnetic tube rack in
order to bind the disc which is
paramagnetic to the wall
and so that you can do easy buffer
washing steps as well
so this begins with approximately 10
milligrams of solid tissue that's minced
and then blended i use a hydrogen tissue
rupture for that
and then um and start comparison to
previous protocols
which use the agarose plug method this
has this has been vastly improved
the previous method you would embed the
dna inside an aggress plug for
many washing and digestion steps which
would take place over a number of days
typically at least three or so
and i could process maybe four samples
during that time and i was lucky if
maybe
three quarters of them were successful
and then running them on the machine i
would sometimes get
100x coverage sometimes i would get
lucky and get closer to 300 but
this new improved protocol in about five
hours i can process about six samples
starting from solid tissue taking it all
the way to ultra high molecular weight
dna
and easily obtain greater than three
injects coverage of the genome
so after the blending process it's the
sample was passed through a 40
micrometer
filter it's pelleted and washed followed
by a lysine protein fk digestion
and then you add the nanobindisk which
binds the dna and you can see the image
to the right is kind of how the dna
appears it's kind of this wispy
cotton-like substance that falls from
the disc and there are numerous
inversion steps
in order to improve binding of the dna
to the disc
including many washing steps as well and
then after illusion you're done and then
the process is pretty simple overall
moving on to the body nano genome
imaging platform
after the isolation step which is the sp
which is solution phase
the dna is then labeled using dls
direct label staining they have a dle
enzyme
which state stains the dna at a six base
pair
sequence motif that repeats throughout
the human genome and so by doing this it
creates a kind of molecular barcode on
the dna
then you take this dna and load it on a
sapphire chip
so you can see the bottom right what
these kind of look like you can load
three samples
on a single chip they then loaded onto
the
render sapphire instrument which you can
see in the bottom left
which then takes multiple images of the
dna as it passes through
and repeated cycling to scan the genome
algorithms and convert these images into
digital molecules
which are overlapped to create consensus
genome maps
of your sample which are then compared
to a reference like the hg-38 human
reference in order to
detect structural variants like
insertions deletions translocations
you can see the labeling based on the
staining of these kind of lines that you
see
here's a schematic of the sapphire chip
so the dna is loaded in
and becomes untangled in the pillars and
then becomes linearized in the nano
channels
and so you can see in the bottom left
how dna is kind of coiled up when it's
in screen solution
and with that but passing through this
chip it's able to become linearized and
then on the right side you can see what
it actually looks like
when the samples are being run in the
sapphire instrument you can see that the
dna in general is being labeled in this
blue
and you have these very long strands
again this is a high molecular weight
dna
and then the green dots are where the
dna has been stained
using the dle to create this kind of
molecular barcode that we can then load
an image multiple times
to create something like this and so the
sample so the cancel
sample for for example is shown in blue
and the different
the lines on the the blue are the
gaining
pattern and then you can see that in
green is the
reference so for for what i do it's
typically hd38
also has the banding pattern and any
differences that are detected can
be used to decide uh the presence of
structural variants
and all the images you're seeing on the
bottom there in orange are just examples
of these digital molecules that span
the region this is a
little closer view of how the structural
variants are called by comparing the
label patterns
you can see for example on the top left
how a deletion looks so you see there's
bending on the green human reference and
then compared to
the cancer sample for example in blue
there's a region there that's that's now
missing and so that's where the deletion
has occurred
and you can see similarly for insertion
between those two
regions where we used to have bands
there's now an additional band and a
different
additional uh dna so that's what we call
an insertion
and there's this type of method to call
these different structural variants
now translocation for example the top
green
refers to a given chromosome when the
bottom green can
compare to a different chromosome for
example or even the same
that's what we call the de novo pipeline
because you're building a
reference you're building a genome de
novo based on just overlaps of your
molecules and then you compare it to a
reference genome so you build the de
novo first and then compare
we have another pipeline called the
verivarian pipeline
that does not create a denovo assembly
but instead directly compares
the digital molecules to a reference
genome so hg-38
and this allows for detection of scs at
a smaller allele fraction down to five
percent
but it may miss smaller events like some
insertions deletions that
may be picked up better at de novo the
river in pipeline does require
approximately 300x coverage
of the reference compared to about 80x
for dinobo
with the sv tissue the isolation
i'm pretty easy now to obtain at least
200xid samples so
i can kind of go through both pipelines
and see the results
moving on now to tongue cancer
the traditional risk factors for tongue
cancer which is predominantly squamous
cell carcinoma include smoking and
alcohol
and so because of this patients tend to
be a bit older
in the 60s 70s and have long histories
of smoking and drinking
however it's been noted in the
literature that there's an increase in
oil cavity cancers which include tongue
and those less than 45 years old and
these
are theorized to be mostly females who
really don't have the traditional risk
factors like smoking and drinking
the question that's been raised is that
is if these tongue cancers in these
young patients
is genetically different than in elderly
patients with the traditional
risk factors and this of course could
have implications for
different diagnostic prognostic and
treatment methodologies
so taking a closer look at the
literature on the mutational profile
between these young and elderly tongue
cancers
some reports which are based on
shortbread sequencing
tend to reach the conclusion that the
profiles are overall pretty similar
however some
in particular with p53 cite more or less
mutations from the young cohort
but there's not a clear pattern overall
there's also not a clear cutoff for when
young and old is used in studies it's
generally been recognized
recommended now to use less than 30 for
young although
the frequency of these tumors is quite
rare and that can be a challenge in
itself
but in general the literature is kind of
conflicting on whether there's a
difference
and so the question i want to ask is if
i could use optical mapping with bio
nano
to help us identify large complex
structural variants that may differ
between young and elderly lung cancer
sequencing is quite good at detecting
smaller events but for larger and more
complex structural variants it can
sometimes mix them or
be hard to interpret them and so using
this different technology you can get a
different view of the cancer
and perhaps we can identify genetic
drivers that can improve our therapies
and so for the genome imaging from bio
nano that i'll show these are using a
rivarian pipeline so again about 300x
coverage
and i use the hc38 reference genome and
for these i'm using
a filter of the binary controls to view
ones that are
to do structural variants that are not
present in any of the controls i have
here's the first tongue cancer i'm
showing this is the elderly patient so
60 years old
square muscle carcinoma some carcinoma
and this is mostly
insertion solutions and first like this
go over what we see on the left image
here so this is a
circles plot which is the description of
the bio nano
data and so on the outside we can see
that numbered from one to 24 are the
chrome
different chromosomes beneath that we
see the chromosomal banding pattern
and then in the box below that we see
where the structural variants
are located and these are all color
coded and so you can see on the
top right this box here different colors
correspond to different
structural variants like insertions
deletions etc so insertions are shown in
this kind of dark green
and what you can see on chromosome one
for example there's three different
insertions
and then on chromosome three there's a
deletion in that region and any of these
structural variants
within the software you can click on
them and then you get taken to a map to
view it in more detail
below that box where the structural
variants are you can see this line
that's kind of plotted across
and this is where copy number variation
is plotted and so for this sample the
copy number is
not very variable uh it goes around it's
mostly
pretty stable you can see on chromosome
22 there's these small little red bands
going down that indicates a loss of copy
number in that area
the contrast on 23 for example is a
small blue tick up and that will be an
increase in copy number but overall
not much copy number variation for this
sample within the center we see where
different translocations
are being shown for example you can see
between
chromosomes six and seven as a
translocation
and again you can click on these events
as well for a closer view
so overall for this elderly tongue
cancer mostly insertion solutions
a few translocations duplications and
not much in terms of copy number
variation
if i take a closer look at the different
genes that are involved in structural
variations
i see that it affects quite a different
number of pathways
and so for example there's a deletion in
the cnk sr1 gene
which regulates rest signal rash
signaling
now you see a translocation involving
cdk6 which promotes the g1s transition
insertions affecting different rasa
genes involved in the ras map cadmium's
pathway
as well as a deletion in the apobec3f
gene which is involved in dna gammas
which have been implicated recently in
literature for head and back cancer
and there's also different gene fusions
that are being detected so there's one
in particular
above the translocation that involves
radical d1b
which is involved in dulce and dna
repair
so here's how the different structural
variants look um using genome
imaging and so on on the very top you
can see the chromosomal
banding and then below that is where
copy number is populated with a green
line so
generally here we're not seeing too much
copy number variation
uh beneath that we see this kind of
purple bar
that indicates the different genes and
this is using hg38 so this gene here
we're seeing is cdk6
and then the light blue
bar is the young the elderly tongue
cancer
genome that we created using the
rivarian pipeline
and so you can see again the bands that
are located on the genome
which is after standing with the uh
daily
you create that kind of molecular
barcode and it's being compared to the
green
which is the reference and so on top you
see chromosome seven
you see that most of the bandings on the
left side are matching up but then once
we get towards kind of the middle of the
screen
the banding starts to line up with
chromosome 18. and so what we're
seeing here then is a translocation and
as well on chromosome 18 it also looks
like there's a
inversion as well
here we see the same cancer now this is
what the deletion
in acobat3f looks like and so again we
can see a region of banding
on the green hd38 reference for
chromosome 22 that is lost now
for our tongue cancer indicating a
deletion
and if you look the on the tongue cancer
genome which is in the pale blue there
there's a darker blue line which
indicates the
coverage for that area and so for
example where this deletion happens
is actually very quite high coverage
supports that read
we're going now to the rad 51b
translocation
you can see similarly here the
chromosome 14 and chromosome
7 is this translocation event for this
tongue cancer
and you're also able to view the
individual digital molecules themselves
to see
how it supports the structural variant
and so all these
kind of yellow lines on the bottom here
are individual digital molecules
you can see that there are a number of
them that span this region
between these two different chromosomes
supporting this translocation call
here is another elderly tongue cancer
this patient was 63.
again squamous cell carcinoma a pretty
similar story to the previous um
cancer mostly insertion deletions
although this one has a bit more
duplications translocations as well it's
a moderate copy number variation
um you can see for example on chromosome
3 this region here where the blue
upticks outwards from the circle and it
can make an increase in copy number
and chromosome 9 for example you can see
some loss of copy number with the red
lines going down
looking at the genes for this sample we
can
again see a variety of different
pathways involved
there's a duplication that involves the
rats of five genes while the brass
domain
a duplication and they went to gene uh
which of course is a trans
transcription factor activator and then
we have a
translocation that involves cc and d2
involved in the c2 cdk4 complex in
hippit's rb
moving on now to some of these younger
lung cancer patients
so this squamous carcinogen of the 26
year old
and we can see that they have quite a
bit more in certain solutions
particularly deletions
compared to the two previous elderly
cases
um and then copy number for this is
pretty moderate as well so for three we
can see regions there
where the blue is up ticking showing
increased copy number variation
now this patient has quite a large
variety of structural variants
and we can see there's a deletion in
akt3 so signal regulator
a translocation involving b raf um both
tiny signaling and also reloading a gene
fusion
a translocation that involves pcl2
l1 involved in apoptosis
as well as insertion tau k3 this is the
activator map kinase
a deletion of stk24 which involved in
maximus pathway
an insertion in nlk which is involved in
one symmony
the next young tongue cancer patient is
a 34 year old
and this one has a quite rich number of
deletions that you can see so again
in that orange color and you can see
them being populated throughout the
genome so in chromosome 2
and 3 throughout you'll see many many
deletions
i mean there's also a significant number
of increasing copy numbers so let's say
on chromosome three and four that we're
seeing
for this patient um we again see
involvement of different pathways um so
it includes a deletion in
fh it developed in apoptosis
uh inversion duplication going map 4k2
kinase signaling duplication involving
rihgb modern grass signaling
so if you look at these two young tongue
cancers compared to
the two elderly you can notice a trend
in different pathways that are involved
of course we're comparing two young
versus two elderly so it's not a
quite a large uh comparison yet but
there's already some things you can
start to take away
and so for the young patients we can see
that the map kinase pathway
is heavily involved in both of these
patients
and we can see hypothesis as well is
affected in both pathways predominantly
as well as wind signaling on the elderly
side
in comparison we have involvement at the
level of brass
as well as the g1s transition
although one of these also does involve
the wind signaling as well
although genes that i underlined are
ones that are implicated in some
literature
that support a difference between young
and elderly so the underlying ones
are hypothesized to be more involved
with young tongue cancer
and so even just between this early
comparison here we can see that
this holds up so far that most of these
genes that they've been identified
are supported by the genome imaging of
our nano and so we can further
isolate more patients and follow up on
these results to see if this holds true
as well as to look for other trends that
perhaps are missed with traditional
sequencing
because we're able to use such larger
pieces of dna
another look at just some of the
different genes that are involved in
young versus elderly
so again the young we have evolved b
raft bcl2 of apoptosis
compared to the more rash signaling
elderly side
here's a brief description of the
different structural variants between
the
the two young versus two elderly
patients at the bottom i sum them up and
the biggest uh notable finding is that
the deletions are so much
larger in frequency for the younger
patients so almost
more than two times the count
of deletions in the young population as
well as more duplications as well
although the one
elderly tongue case tongue cancer only
had five duplications so perhaps that's
an outlier
but anyway things to follow up on for
future
uh future isolations perhaps there's
more copy number variation as well in
these other cases
this is a brief chart review that i did
for these two these two patients
in each group what i want to point out
is that the smoking history for these
young patients one that was 26 and one
was 34
is non-existent there's no smoking
history and very little alcohol use and
so these are the traditional risk
factors again for tongue
cancer and these patients don't have
that and they're quite young as well
in comparison these elderly patients
which are at least 60 have
40 pack years smoking and a bit more
alcohol exposure
so that difference is one of the main
reasons why we're interested in pursuing
this comparison between tongue cancer
according to age
the other difference that stands out at
least at this stage that the
differentiation of these cancers for the
young patients is a bit more well
differentiated
in comparison for the older patients
it's more moderate or poorly
differentiated
in the future i'd like to pursue this
with some more um
more patients and see if these trends
hold up and other patterns we can
identify
what we can see is perhaps the we're
seeing consistently more deletion
duplication among this younger cohort
if there's more copy number variation
that they're more likely to be well
differentiated
again that's a conflicting point in the
list for whether these tongue cancers
among the young
or or better or worse prognostically
it's unclear right now if these patients
are
are better off or if they fare worse
than these hillbilly patients so it's
certainly something that i'm excited to
pursue further
the next cancer this is anaplastic
thyroid this is undifferentiated thyroid
cancer
it accounts for a pretty small
proportion of thyroid cancers globally
as well as one percent or up to 10 tend
to be
older about 65 and predominantly female
and if note this has very rapid
progression poor treatment outcome
and mortality base basically approaches
100 for these patients they
they fare quite poorly and their
breathing is disrupted quite early in
the disease state
so i'm interested in taking a look at
these highly aggressive cancers and
seeing what we can see
um using genome imaging this hasn't been
applied before
so looking at this patient we can see a
variety of insursence deletions some
modest
type number variation chromosome 17 for
example a reason
region of increase and another reason of
decrease and a few translocations
involving chromosomes one two and seven
looking at the genes involved here you
can see there's an insertion involving
the prk
cz gene lb pkc signaling
and duplication involving avr gene
called the gtpas activation
the next thyroid patient
has a number of different insertions and
deletions that are detected
not much in a way of copy number of
variation of one translocation between
four and ten
so the station had an insertion in
cdk11b involved in cell cycle control
as well as an insertion of the abr gene
in duplication going to k12
transcription regulation which resulted
in a gene fusion
here's where the cdh1 insertion looks
you can see that the blue representing
the cancer
has a region here that's been increased
and that's resulting in this insertion
compared to the reference genome so you
can see the molecules below that support
this event
are quite rich spinning this region so
there's a lot of support putting into
this
seat
final anaplastic thyroid cancer example
is here
i've note this one has very extensive
loss of topical variation so you can see
all these red bands all across the
genome integrating loss of copy number
which is quite interesting
and again again this has uh
predominantly insertion solutions
as well as a couple of translocations
involving chromosome 1 in particular
taking a closer look at these genes we
can see there's an insertion in the
ccno2 gene
gold recycling transcription regulation
as well as a duplication involving grad
18
uh ubiquitous protein ligase
one of the ways we can further analyze
data using genome imaging
is to apply different better mask files
and so one potential file
identifies structural variants that are
involved in different kinases and so
this can represent potential drug
targets
and so i've pulled some of the findings
for these different
cancers so far and i noticed the
potential
targets so these are different tinies
that are involved and then they can look
and see in the literature whether
there are drugs that then target that
for example so for the first thyroid
patient
they had a aak1 structural variant
and that can be targeted using synthetic
or lotinib for example
and so something like this is a pretty
easy way to analyze your samples to see
what
potential drug targets there could be
and can lead to further investigation
moving on now to human papillomavirus
this is a double-stranded circular dna
virus
it's notable for having um two viral
oncoproteins e6 and e7
that are thought to be pretty critical
for its role in in cancer development
so e7 disrupts rb and e6 response p53
now hpv is notable for being involved in
cervical cancer
but also in head and neck head and neck
we notice that it's predominantly hpv-16
although there's a smaller proportion of
other subtypes like hpv-33
so in that cancer of the oropharynx
which is essentially the
middle throat we think predominantly
tonsils and base of tongue it's quite
different depending on whether it's a
classic form
basically non-hpv whether it's hpv
induced
the classic form tends to be elderly
patients 60 in the 60s and 70s
and predominantly associated with risk
factors like smoking alcohol they tend
to have pretty high mortality
and some sensitivity to chemo radiation
in comparison hpv induced squamous cell
carcinoma the oropharynx
they tend to be younger so in their 40s
and 50s
and again affects lymphoid tissue so
that's tonsil basaton
mortality is lower and they tend to have
higher sensitivity became a radiation
although it's unclear why there are
certain patients that don't respond
quite as well
now overfrontial cancer in the united
states overall has been increasing
in recent decades and has been driven by
hvp positive cancer
in the graph to the right we can see
that in the the black circles
show hpv negative orifice so that would
be the traditional classic form
scoring cell carcinoma in this region
attributable smoking and alcohol
that's been declining largely because of
decreasing smoking rates in the united
states
over the blue line it represents hpv
positive disease which has been
increasing steadily
and it has increased to the current day
and so we're looking at hpv and ketone
cancers
and we're realizing that there are three
main forms that are described in the
literature
mostly um hypothetically there hasn't
been cheaper detailed evidence for this
so the hpv can be integrated into the
human genome
it can exist as a viral episome so
that's separate from the human genome
as a ring it's thought to be or a viral
human hybrid episode
and so it's some type of ring form that
includes human dna perhaps integrates
and pops out or something along those
lines
it's also been described that
integration can disrupt the viral
e1 e2 gene and if note e2 is a viral
repressor for e6 and e7 which were those
viral oncoproteins i noted before
and so therefore it's hypothesized that
the integrated form has increased e6 e7
activity
which can lead to increased genomic
instability in cancer formation so
perhaps these patients are
very poor when they have this integrated
form
much of what we know about hpv hpv's
role in cancers from cervical cancer
where a very large portion of it
of hpv is integrated i thought that in
head and neck there might be a larger
portion that is
episomal so although still mostly
integrated thought to be but the
episomal form is thought to be
more involved so our question was
whether we could
combine optical mapping using bio nano
as well as whole genome sequencing
using alumina platform to characterize
the molecular state of hpv and
heterogeneous cancers whether it's
integrated episomal
and the implication of this research is
that we can develop a platform to
identify and describe the
third state of hpv and these head and
neck cancers and perhaps associate with
patient outcomes we'll be able to
improve our treatment plans for patients
who might need more aggressive therapy
or patients who might need
a little bit less and so they can have
less morbidity
now for comparison whole genome
sequencing and optical mapping with bio
nano
you can see that whole genuine
sequencing is better at detecting
smaller mutations so less than 50 base
pairs single base per mutations
and this of course is based on
relatively small dna fragments often
less than 500 base pairs
the comparison bio nano uses dna
segments that are at least 150 000 days
growing length
but because of that it's much better at
detecting these large and complex
structural variants
and so because sequencing is better at
these smaller events and by mono and
better at these larger events we're
going to
use both on our approach
here's an example of a base of tongue
cancer
that's hpv positive again we're looking
at the circus plot
chromosomal banding pattern underneath
fabulous structural variants that are
and then beneath that we have the copy
number variation and the translocation
shown
in the middle now looking at the whole
genome sequencing of this
uh this is mapping actually to the hpv33
reference
although it only accounts for about 10
11 percent of these cancers
we found one here and we know that there
are chimeric reads of these reeds that
map both the viral and human
they integrate that indicate integration
into the human genome in this region
now based on those sequencing
coordinates you can then go back to the
volume nano and look at what this event
looks like in very close detail and so
we can see for example
on the top we see the hd38 even
reference and beneath that is our tumor
genome
and these are created using the denoble
pipeline
and we can see that in this region here
the hpv33 virus inserts itself
and then there's a duplication event
that includes the virus and the
surrounding region of the genome
they create this new segment so by
combining the sequencing platform along
with bio nano
we can come up with data like this which
is quite interesting to see
the same patient had a translocation
disrupting the retinoblastoma gene that
you can see here
a large region here that gets deleted
from the reference and inserted
different region
this is a second patient uh with tonsil
cancer
and for this one we have both tumor and
lymph node isolated and for the bio nano
strikingly there's essentially no
structural variants that are detected
we go to the whole genome sequencing
this one in fact maps to the hpv-16
reference
and we can note that there's 19 copies
of the virus per cell but there are no
chimeric reads indicating that
the virus is not integrated in the
sample the region between the red arrows
you can see
some areas of decreased mapping so that
hpv reference
but there's no chimeric reason so it's
not integrated and so that we therefore
think that this is
more likely to be at episomal form
this third example is a tonsil cancer
now this one has a number of different
circular variants so deletions for
example on chromosomes 10 11
12 and a variety of different trend
locations it's a moderate
copy number variation as well
the whole genome sequencing for this you
can notice these two reasons here with
these
decreased mapping these actually where
there are chromatic reads that are
detected
this hpv-16 coverage and you can use
these integration positions based on the
sequencing
to line it up to the structural variant
we see using genome imaging without nano
you can see that this region here where
the virus is
presumed to be inserted based on
sequencing that we can see that an
insertion happens somewhere the red
arrow is
and we can see actually that this kind
of repeats itself multiple times in the
region as well
so again by combining both platforms
we're able to get
detail that you can't really obtain
without a technology alone
the last example here is another tonsil
cancer and again
for this one we see no structural
variants and so if it fits the paradigm
from before we expect to go to
sequencing and notice that
we don't see any chimeric reads and so
that would be more indicative of
episomal form
and so for these episomal cancers
because they don't really have these
structural variants or optical mapping
we're more we're interested in looking
at the sequencing data further to
identify different synths
involved in different uh cell pathways
so no what we've seen so far and this
has been extended to about a dozen more
samples is that
for samples that we can identify
integrated events and sequencing we find
this kind of global genomic instability
for these hpv cancers
i'm using genome imaging but if we don't
find a sequencing event and it matches
up with these
genome maps where there's not really
many structural variants so it seems to
to suggest that these integrated forms
have greater genomic instability than
the episomal
if you look at the clinical info between
these groups we can
take note of a number of differences so
an integrated hpv cancers tend to be a
bit more advanced in stage
and are associated with more disease
recurrence as well
the mean tumor size is quite a bit
bigger in these integrative forms 3.4
centimeters for the 2.5 ribosomal as
well as a larger metastatic focus in
one's mode
a very neural invasion and lipovascular
invasion
are signs that the cancer has invaded
into either nerve
or vessel and are associated with poor
prognosis and these are also more
associated in these integrated forms
so by combining optical mapping geometry
from bionato
with whole genome sequencing we can
detect the state of these hpv genomes
and my cancer
they've noticed with the integrative
form they have greater genomic
instability
and they have worse clinical outcomes so
perhaps these integra integration
factors for hpv can become
more important for parents and treatment
planning going forward
adrenal imaging is able to construct
these complicated genomic alterations
that were previously
unidentifiable using whole genome
sequencing alone so we've had
a lot of success studying these by
combining combining both platforms
so in conclusion these solution phase
soft tissue high microwave unit
isolation protocol
released recently developed from bionino
was highly efficient easy to follow
much improved compared to the previous
agarose plug method
and by combining with the latest
sapphire instrument and check technology
can reliably
reach greater than 300 extreme coverage
for these solid tumors
i've been able to successfully apply
this framework to
a variety of head and neck cancers so
for tongue cancer there's some early
results that
suggest possible genetic differences
between young and elderly tongue cancer
i'm able to identify a variety of
structural variants and highly lethal
anaplastic thyroid cancer
and in conjunction with whole genome
sequencing being able to identify hpv
insertion sites in association with high
genomic instability
with hpv integration
i like to acknowledge dr broach dr
goldenberg as well as bionato for their
support
and some references here now i'm happy
to take
any questions
thank you for that excellent
presentation dr lavarge
it is now time for our live q a session
of our webinar
now before we dive in i just want to
remind our audience how to submit
questions
if you have a question you'd like to ask
do it now and
just type them into the ask a question
box on the far left of your screen
click send and we will get to as many
questions as we have time for
okay let's dive in dr labarz let's start
with this question
can you start looking for events that
are
cancer drivers initiation of cancer
not result of cancer
yes definitely that's that's something
we're of course considering
um at this stage we've mostly been
working with
cancers that have already formed and so
it's hard to look at the initiation
stage
although if we were able to study for
example
some type of model perhaps a cell line
we have different stages
known stages of cancer development for
example if you have
hvp cell line and then you can see that
you can monitor the progress to see
basically where the cancer develops and
if you
use these type of platforms you can try
to see when it happens or what kind of
events are happening
for them
now dr labarge for tongue cancer you
explain the differences
between older and younger cases very
clearly
can you explain why you think that is
what is the cause of the differences and
are these lifestyle or genetic
differences that cause early or late
onset
the why is what we're trying to figure
out and it's not really clear why
why the difference is as far as
lifestyle
the traditional risk factors smoking
alcohol aren't there for these younger
patients
typically and at least not there for the
type of period that the elderly patients
are experiencing them so it's less clear
of what lifestyle
interaction could be behind that as far
as genetic differences
these two young young tongue cancer
patients do not have any family history
of
of cancer like that so it's unclear then
what the genetic difference could be
but that's something that we're looking
into and it's been noted that there are
different um
gene pathways that are types that tend
to be involved so young versus elderly
although it's conflicting and we're able
to replicate some of that with this
genome imaging and i want to look into
that more going forward
thank you when structural vari
variants are subclonal do you get data
on which variants occur together
in the same cells
i don't i don't think that information
is accessible
um based on genome imaging alone as far
as i know
thank you how much does it cost to
analyze a genome with optical map
optical mapping roughly
in my experience it's about 400 or so
per genome for optical obstacle mapping
my experience with sequencing has been
that it takes that's more
closer to 1500 or so per sample and so
the
the price point is is um is definitely
in five nine's favor for that
thank you now dr lobar have you tried
calling structural variants based on the
whole genome sequence
data
we are looking into that particularly
for the those hpv samples to see what
variants we can call by
whole genome sequencing and then we're
going to follow that up by comparing to
the optical mapping
to see how much overlap there is or if
there's different types of svs that are
detecting the different platforms
thank you now we have time for a few
more questions but i do want to let our
audience know that any questions we are
unable to answer
today due to time restraints they will
be answered
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
okay let's squeeze in a few more now dr
lavar
if i understand correctly you used a set
of common sds to retain
only rare svs occurring in the patients
how many genomes were used to build the
set of
common sps and which genomes did you use
did you sequence non-tumor tissue from
the same patients
so for the tongue and thyroid stations
did not do any sequencing um but for
those that did use the rare variant
pipeline which i think you're
alluding to so that pipeline is able to
detect variants that
can happen at low frequency 65 but it's
not limited to only detecting rare
structural variants
and so each of those tumors i was able
to generate a genome for each one
and then compare that to reference to
determine different structural variants
thank you and dr lobarge we have time
for one more question
can crispr techniques help in finding a
cure for cancers
caused due to genetic mutation or
through heredity
yes i think there's a great potential um
with using crispr for this
for this purpose i think for for optical
mapping in particular can be helpful
for example if we're able to determine a
way to crispr label
h516 virus then we can
label these tumors and then see exactly
what the virus is
quite easily and then based on that we
can
study it more closely and perhaps not
rely on the sequencing to
determine where the virus is this can
kind of speed up the process but i think
it definitely has a great potential and
can be applied to different viruses that
are oncogenic in nature as well
you dr lavarge and thank you for this
excellent q a
session you've given us a lot of
information do you have any final
comments for our audience
i'd like to thank everyone for tuning in
i appreciate you spending your time
taking a listen and um just wanted to
really
reiterate that my experience using the
platform has been
quite promising so far for a variety of
headache tumors and
the sd tissue in particular protocol has
made
isolation so much easier than the
previous agarose plug method so if you
have solid tissue tumors that you're
interested in it's
definitely something to look into
thank you and dr lavarge i'm going to
pull an audible real quick and i want to
throw in one more question that came in
i think this is a great one
how are the structural variants filtered
and what pipeline was used
so for tongue and thyroid
i used the very variant pipeline because
with the
sb tissue i was able to achieve greater
coverage of the reference so with 300x i
can then use that river and pipeline and
see
what types of variants are there
including ones that are quite rare
which we might miss with lower coverage
uh the filtering for those i used
the most stringent settings possible for
the um
binomial controls so bionite has
reference genomes that they have and
you can set it so basically any
structural variants that you see are not
present in any of the binaural controls
and that's what i use for those
for the hpv data those were done a bit
uh a bit older using the agarose plug
method because of those i used the noble
pipeline
because that's what existed at the time
and plus i was getting around 100x
because of the aggress plug method
although if i had used sv tissue which
is now available i can
i might be able to get 300x and on some
of them i did reach higher levels
and i applied that to the rare variant
as well
and in those cases i actually
also filtered out by the patient blood
any germline mutations just just to see
what was somatic
for those hpv ones
thank you so much and thank you for your
time today and your important research
i also want to thank lab roots and i
want to thank our sponsor
bio nano genomics for underwriting
today's educational webcast
now before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and again
for their interesting question
we have quite a few questions we are
unable to answer today so those
questions
that came in today and we weren't able
to answer and additionally those that
are submitted during our on-demand
period
they will be addressed by dr lavarch via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
one more thank you to dr brandon labart
and
we thank you for joining us today's
webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab roots will alert you via email
when it is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us stay healthy
stay safe and have a great day
you